lux y marc muchas gracias por estar aquí
en radio canadá internacional cómo estás
qué bueno lo que hemos convertimos
conversado en otras ocasiones sobre este
tema es un tema que nos interesa a ambos
y radio canadá está tomando decisiones
bien concretas con respecto a la
diversidad a la inclusión dentro del
marco de sus producciones y dentro del
marco de su personal también porque
recientemente katrin kate presidenta
directora general de radio canadá hizo
un anuncio que nos llamó la atención
porque es nuevo y requiere compromisos
concretos por parte de los productores
con los que radio canadá trabaja de qué
se trata exactamente cuéntanos bueno hay
que saber que la mayoría en mayoría de
los programas que ponemos al aire son
hechos con productores independientes lo
que quiere decir es que no son empleados
de radio que nada son gente afuera de
radio canadá con quien trabajamos para
de solidad qué tipo de programas
y programas de ficción programas de
variedades documentarios etcétera
etcétera entonces es muy importante
porque cuando se mira la guía va ahorrar
ya digamos de radio canadá la mayoría de
los programas son hechos con esos
productores independientes afuera de la
lluvia en colaboración en colaboración
el resto de los programas programas de
información como lo que está haciendo
son hechos con nuestro personal nuestros
empleados eso es cosa diferente entonces
lo que anunció la señora tere es muy
importante porque decimos sus
productores con quién trabajamos que
necesitamos y nos damos algunos años
para alcanzarlo necesitamos que ellos se
emplean en uno de los puestos más
importantes de la producción que sea
productor mismo que sea guionista que
sea director y actor principal desde su
producción si se trata de una ficción
que sea una persona de la diversidad
diversidad incluyendo digamos minoría
visible
gente digamos
autóctonos y este tipo de gente es muy
importante porque en este momento no se
hace hay muy poco muy poca gente de la
diversidad trabajando por los
productores independientes entonces eso
va a ser algo fantástico tenemos que
notarlo
tenemos cifras en cuanto a esta falta de
diversidad en las producciones
independientes e incluso internas de
radio canadá hay alguna cifra que
podemos darle a la gente para que se den
una idea de por qué es importante
qué lástima no tenemos cifras exactas
acerca de los productores independientes
lo que sabemos porque trabajamos con
ellos que a muy pocos productores de la
diversidad muy pocos directores de la
diversidad lo que tenemos un poco más
son actores de la diversidad entonces lo
que hacemos nosotros era yo canadá
cuando trabajamos digamos con un
productor independiente para producir
una ficción es que exigimos que sea un
cierto número de los actores sean
actores de la diversidad para que haya
una representación de la población que
servimos y bueno se trata de mostrar el
toque a la edad de una población la
población de guadix bastante
diversificada entonces ya hacemos
digamos cierta presión para tener
actores de la diversidad lo que no hemos
hecho
no hemos podido hacer mejor dicho hasta
ahora es influir a nivel de productor a
nivel de guionista a nivel de director
en eso hace la diferencia
porque es importante este tipo de
iniciativas porque hay otras iniciativas
esta es una que fue anunciada esta
semana aquí por la directora presente
presidente directora general de radio
canadá pero hay otras iniciativas que
radio canadá ha puesto en marcha porque
es importante que un productor como
radio canadá tenga esto bien claro pues
es una cuestión bastante simple de
alcanzar a los gustos del público de
contestar digamos de adaptarnos a los
cambios demográficos y a los gustos del
público
entonces ese público que es más y más
diversificado está esperando que una
organización pública como nosotros va a
contestar esos esos deseos esas demandas
entonces se trata de superviviencia en
el futuro para aclarar lo que nada
tenemos que estamos digamos al tanto del
público de acuerdo a la evolución de
nuestro público por eso son cosas
fundamentales para el futuro
y ya se sabe que la tiene bastante
fondos públicos fundida por fondos del
gobierno fondos anuales normalmente y no
son todos los gobiernos tenemos 82 años
de existencia no son todos los gobiernos
del pasado tampoco del futuro que
a quienes les gusta tanto a reeducar
entonces la única manera de asegurar la
supervivencia de derrocarlo es de tener
el soporte y el apoyo del público y para
tener ese apoyo hay que corresponder a
los deseos del público entonces eso es
fundamental para que otras iniciativas
vienen acompañando esta iniciativa que
fue presentada esta semana hay otras
podemos dar algunas brevemente bueno a
nivel de empleos que tenemos tenemos
un nivel digamos de empleados de la
universidad que no es suficientemente
alto en este momento entonces hacemos
esfuerzos también para emplear a gente
diferente eso se da lentamente por una
razón
la mayoría de nuestros empleados son
miembros de sindicatos digamos cuando
que consigues la permanencia
te quedas la mayoría de los de los
empleados se quedan por a largo plazo
entonces se necesita tiempo para cambiar
digamos
el retrato de los empleados pero
regresamos seguramente estamos
progresando y hay otras hay otras
tenemos iniciativas con los autos
tenemos por ejemplo porque un desafío
más difícil de alcanzar que los demás es
emplear
un cierto número de autóctonos
y que se bueno que tengan placer de
trabajar aquí y que se quedan en unidad
porque al contrario de lo que estaba
diciendo acerca de la mayoría de los
empleados que cuando tienen su
permanencia se quedan no es lo mismo con
los autóctonos en este en este momento
en la experiencia que tenemos es que si
los empleamos a un cierto número de
ellos pero se van no se quedan entonces
el objetivo es emplear y conservar a los
colegas autóctonos que vamos a emplear
en los años siguientes próxima director
de la inclusión de las comunidades
muchas gracias por venir aquí